new fallout for Matt Lauer as more women
come forward with sexual misconduct
allegations against him also new
questions raised over NBC's call to
scrap Ronan Pharos explosive findings on
Harvey Weinstein did the network know
the piece might eventually lead back to
Lauer more on that in a moment the
disgraced Morning News anchor released
an apologetic statement today but
disputes some of the occupations he says
there are no words to express my sorrow
and regret for the pain I have caused
others by words and actions some of what
is being said about me is untrue or
mischaracterized but there is enough
truth in these stories to make me feel
embarrassed and ashamed repairing the
damage will take a lot of time and
soul-searching and I'm committed to
beginning that effort you know that's
interesting that's almost the exact same
words that Al Franken use remember from
last week yes where he doesn't
necessarily agree with the woman's
perception of what happened but yes I'm
sorry if I may have given you the
impression but he does say that there's
enough truth in them that the action
that NBC taken the NBC took to fire him
I guess was warranted yeah I mean it was
a finely written statement by an
attorney or a PR executive or an
attorney
Kimberly well it sounds like if there
was no speculation that he was in
Hamptons and then meeting with a friend
who was a criminal defense attorney and
it just depends on the nature of the
allegations if any of them are you know
criminal or assaultive or anything like
that that was without consent and an
unlawful touching so against somebody's
will yeah then he could be in trouble
for that depending on the you know
statute limitations we in the New York
Times today I was reading hustler not
that I ever read it but it's so graphic
you know it's so graphic judging by that
criteria there's a case there right
because this woman's knocked out I just
had to go to a nurse remembers the
situation I mean this looks like
something you would see like unloading
well I think the bigger issues for NBC
because remember NBC in the first
statement says we'd had no prior
knowledge of any complaint or violation
of his kind and then they have to issue
a second statement which says current
management didn't have that kind of
that's how the briefing and which is you
know so they're backpedaling
Brian rapidly and I think that it's not
so much to my mind that he might be in
legal difficulty although Kimberly says
it's possible but it's that the question
of what NBC knew and when they knew it
you know to put it in a sort of Nixonian
water you think that's where this story
goes next Jesse yeah the cover-up is
always worse than the crime and the NBC
brass doesn't look so squeaky-clean
because yesterday they put out this
narrative that they were blindsided by
this
and they took decisive action and there
were no complaints now there were
complaints Meredith Vieira says that he
kept sex toys in his office Hoda and
Savannah apparently knew a lot of this
from reports we're hearing but acted
like they were totally unaware when they
made the announcement and Joe and Myka
over at MSNBC said this was kind of an
open secret I know that's been a banned
phrase here but this was a guy felt away
this was out there and some of it was
consensual but a lot of it was not
consensual a lot it was humiliating
degrading harassment borderline sexual
assault if these reports are true so it
looks like they have a problem because
when you combine them spiking the run
and Farrah Weinstein piece with them
spiking the Juanita Broderick raped Bill
Clinton piece and then basically
protecting Matt Lauer for all these
years
it doesn't look good for them and I knew
they made a half a billion dollars in
profits every year and the ratings were
great and you know that's entices people
to you know cover up stuff like that but
it's a family everything they say it's
you know the Today Show family and
sometimes you're pressured into keeping
things in the family and this is one of
those examples that a lot of attention
today on that famous picture of the two
women hugging on the set because if what
you say is true and they knew and there
was around you know I think mica said
she's not shocked mica mica said she's
not because he watches Fox and Prince he
does not know how to pronounce the name
fan thank you so I think that there's
also an issue about what we mean when we
say consensual mm-hmm because what's
consensual if the young woman is an
ambitious young person at NBC and you're
talking about a man who's paid 20 plus
million dollars a year is
franchises you discussed the money maker
in terms of morning television in
America and and management says you know
what you don't want to go there maybe we
don't want to discuss this right now
what does that say to that young person
I can't touch that there would be
there's so much it's almost like the old
rules it's almost like we're looking
back to like 1980s compared to if a star
gets in trouble we find a way to save
that star whether it's sports or
entertainment or news star it was when
you make 23 million dollars I believe
you're valuable to the franchise
remember when Brian Williams made up
those war stories those are like the
good old days now yeah that's like he's
probably on some level even though he's
friends with Matt Lauer he are to some
degree although you watch Matt Lauer
interview him after that he didn't let
him up for air nor did he let go Riley
up for air at all he was brutally he was
relentless in an interview knowing that
this was in his closet is unbelievable
in retrospect but in the big picture
the next thing when people say what's
next now you see Jake Tapper's the less
than high-profile producer he's gone
okay that's not necessarily next what's
next I think is going to be the
management this is gonna be a gutting of
the management of people who were
playing by the rules that got them where
they were today but the rules say that
this is a huge error what do you think
about the Ronan Farrow PISA Ronan Farrow
is an NBC Today Show fixture and he had
the Harvey Weinstein story NBC said take
it somewhere else is not it's not a
story that we want to do it comes out in
The New Yorker and then that actually is
the spark that lit this wild fire I
think that after you mentioned this
yesterday after a block and we were
talking about the commercial break it's
like things I should have saw it during
a book and that's what I said to Dana
why didn't you say that and make that
point so but we're doing it today I
think it looks very bad for them because
it makes them look like they were trying
to do kind of a cover-up they don't want
to do a story like that and then now
they have their own kind of skeletons in
their closet and it's a you know such a
big story Ronan Farrow obviously was you
know telling the truth and there was an
effort there to try to not talk about
any stories like this and not shine the
light on we're not saying that we know
for sure that it's connected we don't
know it does it has raised
meanwhile pressure is mounting for
congressman john conyers to step down
over allegations of sexual misconduct
top Democrat Nancy Pelosi is now among
several members of Congress to call for
his resignation today that also includes
Jim Clyburn who just yesterday is
reported to have questioned the
accusations made against Conyers this
according to robert draper of the new
york times who tweeted also at this
morning's house Democratic caucus james
Clyburn compared Conyers accusers to the
child murderer susan smith who initially
claimed a black man had abducted her
kids Clyburn said these are all white
women who've made these charges against
Conyers but today Clyburn appears to be
backtracking you said last week that you
thought it was possible all these
allegations could just be made up I've
never said that this was reported I said
when you consider the source of these
just as I've seen the misrepresentation
of comments I made yesterday
Breitbart or somebody that's putting out
the statement that I said that this had
to do with fight witness file and the
command against a black guy that is
absolutely not what I said and the fact
that matter is the young lady in
question so one for a week now ever
since Nancy Pelosi was on Meet the Press
and sort of screwed that one up and now
that a week later calling for the
resignation or the Democrats trying to
get themselves into a place where they
can all agree that these allegations are
serious and that there should be
consequences so there's so much to say
here but I mean you have to put it in
this kind of one Democrats are not
United and not sort of you know all of
one party when it comes to this and so
what you've had is Pelosi trying to
maintain relations with these senior
member of the Democratic delegation in
the US House of Representatives because
you want to show respect to some now is
the 88 years old a senior member of the
party and the head of the Judiciary
Committee but Brian you want to maintain
relations with the Congressional Black
Caucus which was going to be especially
protective of the man who founded the
Congressional Black Caucus and he's
referred to in the black community but
also by Pelosi as an icon but one would
you also
say this would you also say there's the
right thing to do politically and
there's the right thing to do personally
so if you listen to these women talk and
you read off some of these accounts and
you close the book and you go I got to
go do Meet the Press I got to be honest
I cannot back him anymore it's a shame
what I thought he was he turns out he's
not to be that as opposed to I better
not lose the Congressional Black Caucus
your first thing to do I believe is is
do the right thing which Kathleen rice
did
Kathleen rice has been the hero of this
entire thing this belief she's a
freshman right freshmen New York
congresswoman has spoken out on both
sides against she walked oh she said she
walked out of a meeting with Nancy
Pelosi there because they weren't
addressing the elephant in the room
that takes guts telling jet you know
senator Franken to step aside that takes
guts telling this guy this icon to step
aside that takes guts before anybody
else was doing listen I think they are
asking him to step aside they in an hour
do it right away
no but I don't think I think if you're
talking about that institution Brian
there's no getting away from the fact
it's a house of politics and what Nancy
Pelosi wanted to demonstrate that she is
a leader to her members but also then I
think she screwed up on Meet the Press
when she talked about questioning these
women the same screw up and my friend
Jim Clyburn made a parents well she
managed to alienate both constituencies
women and blacks because at first she
said the guy's an icon and raised doubts
about the women and you know the
Democrats need women because they're a
key constituency then she flip-flops and
says he should probably resign but she
hasn't called for the white Al Franken
to resign so a lot of members in the
black community see a little bit of a
different standard there there's you
know this is what actually Greg was
talking about it's such a huge
difference between these cases but you
want to throw them in the same bucket I
just don't think that's fair to people
okay I mean there's similarities between
both to be fair I mean he says for
Conyers accusations against them one
settled groping you know sex is showing
up and underwear Franken photographic
evidence
groping things they are similar in the
same vein i kimberly out though when it
comes to the law or in sexual harassment
is that the women accusing al franken
weren't working for
No is that the that is that the key
distinction well that's it yeah that is
a key distinction because it wasn't
something that was taking place you know
in the work environment where he was a
superior to them there or supervisor etc
so no it's still a completely
non-consensual unwarranted inappropriate
and so that's what makes it so
disturbing you see people think that
they have just free rein to behave in
this way that is injurious to others
into women but when you see the
situation to you know of Conyers and you
see the situation is Franken there is
evidence to substantiate these claims
that is him being independently do you
think the Conyers will resign by
tomorrow well so Conyers in the hospital
yeah absolutely
correct yes and so as Kimberly said you
know this is an 88 year old man under
stress tremendous stress I think you
have to stop for a second I know you
know we don't often do this but you just
be sympathetic for a second the poor
guys whole life has crumbled here
because he is no longer going to be
known as the founder by a caucus or
longest-serving member or a terrific
representative of southeastern Michigan
he's going to be known as the guy who
got caught up in this and by the way to
your point Jesse the real crime in the
Conyers case is that he apparently used
public funds to pay off this woman as
hush money that's the sin here and I
shouldn't would you also say that we
should give tribute to Harvey Weinstein
for doing some great movies I mean if
he's going FIFA if he's doing this for
50 years if it turns out you got to
reshape Bill Cosby's hysterical but I
don't know if I could put on an album
again I will say this a third accuser a
couple hours ago from Al Franken this
Stephanie kempler from 2003 long time
ago before he was senator